[音楽]
はぁ
poo
私は今大学4年生ですが
気候変動ってかなりヤバいと思いながら
日々生活しています
こちらのデータをご覧下さい
現在産業革命児と比べて約1.1度気温が
上昇したと言われています
今後さらに気温が上昇すると大規模な自然
災害が次々と起こってしまうと予測されて
います
ただこういう話って皆さんどこかで聞いた
ことがあったのではないですか
学生であれば教科書で習ったり最近は
ニュースで30年に1度の合意ですと
取り上げられたりします
そして最近では企業も
持続可能な社会に向けた取り組みを始めて
いたりしますよね
こういう環境問題に関する
議論になると最後は
みんなでいすきを変えようと言うと思うん
です
確かに大事ですよね
環境問題解決のためにアクションを増やす
そこに気持ちを高める必要がある
ただこういう椅子機を変えようという言葉
でどれだけの人が変わってきたでしょうか
本当に全国民
全人類の意識を高めることはできるの
でしょうか
そして
意識を高めることは本当にアクションに
繋がっていくのでしょうか
皆さん
学校の宿題を思い出してみてください
宿題が付されてすぐに取り組める人もいれ
ば
締め切りを守ろうと思ってもなかなかでき
ない人
締め切りに迫られているクエストそして
途中で終わってしまう人
そんな人言いましたよね
私は
この状況は
環境問題の桜目の前にした私たちの現状と
似ていると思うんです
ここでいう宿題と環境問題
どちらも動いている人は本当に意識の高い
人なんでしょうか
これをやりたいと強くを思えば
意識しなくとも動けるのではないでしょう
か
こんなデータがあります
あなたにとって気候変動対策はどのような
ものですかという質問に対して我慢を
強いるものと答えた人は日本人では約
60%
世界平均では約25%
日本人の半数以下しかがまんだと思ってい
ません
さらに
あなたにとって気候変動対策は生活の質を
高めるものですかという質問に対しては
日本人の約17%は
生活の質を高めるものと回答しています
世界では約66%の人が生活を高めると
思っています
つまり日本人にとって気候変動対策を
取り組むことには抵抗感が強いのかもしれ
ません
なので私は今目の前に座ってる
あなたの環境意識を高めたいというふうに
は思っていません
ただ
危機的な環境問題解決のためには
アクションを増やす必要があるんです
ではどのようにしたらよいのか
私がアクションを増やすために大切だと
思っていることが2つあります
一つ目は
環境分野で常識にとらわれず変革を起こす
人を増やすことです
私もそのような人でありたいと活動して
いるうちの一人です
このように思うきっかけとなったのは
こちらの動画の中にあります
ということですはいい
これは私が実際に撮影したフィリピンの
ゴミ山の映像です
リゾートホテルの川を挟んだ向こう側に
あります
綺麗な空と対するように見たことのある
プラスチックごみが一面に広がっていまし
た
私はこの景色を見たときすごく衝撃を受け
ました
映像の中の彼女にとってこの後宮間は
通学路であり遊び場なんです
しかし
この問題は遠い国知らない誰かの問題
でしょうか
実は
日本は世界で2番目に多くのプラスチック
ごみを輩出している国だといわれています
送料ではなく一人ひとりの排気量が世界で
兄なんです
私はこのとき自分自身も
このゴミ山を作ってしまっている一人だと
いうことに気がつきました
たしかに日本ではリサイクルもされてい
ますが東南アジアにも輸出しているんです
私はこの現状を変えたい小強く思い日本に
帰国後
環境団体を立ち上げたり日々の生活を
見直したりしてきました
このゴミ問題に取り組むことは温室効果
ガスの削減にもつながります
私は
気候変動による危機で幸せが脅かされない
社会を本気で作りたいと思っています
そのために
アクションを起こすことがポジティブに
捉えられ捉えられるような仕組みを作る
ことでより多くの人に受け入れられて
もらえ
結果的には大きな変革につながると考え
ました
そこで同好きにとらわれず変革を起こす
仕組みをつくる人を増やしていきたいん
です
アクションを増やすために大切だと思って
いることを2つ目は
この仲間と共に作った仕組みを多くの人と
巻き込んで
巻き込むことができた事例を増やすこと
です
これは秩父ジョブズやエジソンなど選ばれ
た五人だけができることではありません
一人一人の家庭でできることです
私は身をもって実感しました
ここで巻き込み事例を増やすために必要な
ことは
きっかけと
継続できる楽しさです
我が家で起きた事例をとともに紹介させて
いただきます
私はある日母に内緒で土を買いました
コロナの自粛期間中
生ごみの削減を目標に
生ごみを土に開始
堆肥化するコンポストをやりたかったから
です
ただ私の母は
土の付いた靴で喧嘩に上ることさえも許さ
れないほど大のキレイ好きです
なので内緒で30 l の父を買いました
母にコンポストについていろいろ説明をし
ましたが臭そ
虫が出そう
なんかまた変なものを買ってきたなと最初
は煙たがられていました
しかしコンポストを始めていくとあらゆる
変化が起きたのです
まず
土と微生物と暮らすこの新しい生活に癒さ
れていたのです
前の日に生ごみを投入し朝起きて
かき混ぜると
生ごみの形を変えぬくもりを見ている姿に
母は明らかにテンションがかかっている
ようでした
そして
朝ごはんを食べているときにはこれを入れ
たらコンポストが喜びそう
昨日の残り油もコンポストに入れてみない
とコンポスト遠く際も繰り広げるように
なりました
もちろん母に生ゴミが与える環境負荷に
ついてやごみの削減について高い関心や
知識があったわけではありません
シンプルにコンポストが面白かったのです
土を強引に買うというきっかけと
微生物がみるみる分解し形を変えていく
楽しさ
これが我が家の生ごみの削減につながり
ました
面白い楽しいと思えることから始めること
で家族を巻き込めたのだと思います
私はこのようにいすきしないでアクション
を起こすことができる
事例をたくさん増やしていくことが大切だ
と思います
最後に皆さんに質問があります
皆さんはどんなアクションがしてみたい
ですか
我慢を強いられて
無理にやる宿題ではなく
楽しみながらやっていたらいつのまにか
終わっていた宿題をしてみませんか
無理せず続けることによってそれは宿題
から日常に変わっているはずです
今では母のものと化したコンポストのよう
に
日常の中で取り組めることはもうすでに
あります
ぜひ身の回りの物を探してみて初めて気み
てくださいありがとうございました
[拍手]